Here's the truth. The reason your
generated sites look bad isn't the fault
of AI. It's the way you're using it. If
you're still going into clawed code and
asking it to build a beautiful website
or make it look premium, then you're
seriously going to get left behind.
Today, I'll show you how to finally
leave those boring generic sites behind
and reveal three powerful methods that
completely change how you build
websites, plus some tricks to take your
work to the next level with the most
powerful coding agent available right
now. Now, the real power of clawed code
in UI comes from iterating repeatedly.
They never tire, making them ideal for
continuous refinement. There's a proper
framework for effective iteration. It's
also really important to use HTML files
during initial iterations. They're much
easier to modify than fully developed
frameworks like Nex.js or React apps.
For repeated iterations, cloud code
stands out with features like /comands
and multiple agent creation
capabilities. But to effectively iterate
on UI designs, you also need the right
visualization tool. This is where
superdesign.dev comes in. They call it
the cursor for design and it lives up to
that name. It provides an interactive
canvas where you can watch your AI agent
create and modify UI iterations in real
time. Previously, this tool had a
significant limitation. We could only
use the built-in agent with a clawed API
key. You couldn't use your existing
cursor or claude code subscription. But
now, they've solved this problem. You
can use their powerful canvas feature
and embedded workflow directly with your
existing Claude Code subscription while
still accessing all the benefits this
remarkable tool provides. So, first let
me show you how to install SuperDesign
and use it with Claude Code. It's a
simple extension that works in both
cursor and VS Code. Open your extensions
tab. Search for SuperDesign and install
it. Once installed, you'll need to open
the canvas view. Press command plus
shift + P to open the command pallet.
Type SuperDesign and select this option
from the menu. This canvas view displays
all your designs in real time, allowing
you to see changes and iterate
immediately. You can also change the
device types to see how your designs
appear on various screens. This is
really useful for testing responsive
layouts. Now, here's how to use the
iterative workflow with Claude code. To
use Claude code, we need to initialize a
claude.md file that they've provided.
This file will contain all the context
and system prompts needed for claude
code to function like their native
agent. Open your command pallet again
with command plus shift + p. Type
superesign and this time select the
initialize superdesign option. This
creates the claude.md file right in your
home directory. Now when you initialize
claude in your current repository, it
automatically loads all the context from
this file and acts like a system prompt
for claude code. The file tells Claude
it's acting as super design, a senior
front-end engineer. It also includes
styling instructions for various
libraries, font specifications, color
schemes, and additional guidelines.
Essentially, it provides all the
information that makes SuperDesign an
excellent design agent. First, we start
with the layout phase for your app. I've
asked Claude Code to build the main home
screen of an Uber app. I requested five
iterations. Claude Code updates its task
list and begins generating the layouts.
At the layout stage, SuperDesign uses
ASKI format to visualize layouts
directly in the terminal, eliminating
the need for code at this point. This
allows quick layout finalization. It
makes the first layout followed by a
second with the search bar repositioned
lower. The third features a split screen
design with the search bar divided into
two fields and it also made two more.
You can easily request modifications.
For instance, if you like the photo
layout but want recent rides instead of
quick actions, you can ask Claude code
to make that change immediately. I
selected the second layout and move to
stage two, theme design. Again, I
requested five iterations focusing on
style and design language variations.
This stage typically includes color
palette suggestions, but I had already
chosen my colors. I used a website
called colors where pressing the space
bar generates different palettes. Once
you find one you like, copy the CSS and
provide it to your coding agent. Claude
Code generated five distinct themes
based on my specifications. These theme
options come from super design system
prompt, but you can provide your own
variations without restrictions. The
results show five uniquely styled
interfaces. One has a cartoonish feel
and another features glass morphism
effects. There's a professional version
and even a neon variation. Super design
also includes built-in utilities. While
the first two serve the agent itself,
the copy prompt function extracts the
design specifications for any HTML file.
This lets you iterate, copy, or export
designs elsewhere. You can also copy the
design path for reference. Though it's
simpler to tell Claude Code which design
you prefer and proceed from there. I
landed on this one design, but I needed
to iterate on it because the color
palette wasn't being properly applied. I
returned to Claude Code and specified
the design file I liked. And then I
explained that the colors weren't being
used effectively and requested five new
variations with better color
implementation. Claude Code updated its
task list and began creating the
variations. The five new designs showed
improved color palette application. Some
went slightly overboard with the colors,
but that's fine since we're iterating,
not finalizing. Among all the
variations, one stood out with the
perfect balance. It didn't go overboard
and used all the colors perfectly. Now,
this is the design that I'll move
forward with. I provided Claude with the
path of my finalized design and
instructed it to delete all other
iterations. Now, I could implement
animation. Claude code completed this
task efficiently. The beauty of
superdesign.dev is that it creates fully
interactive elements. You can click
buttons, type in input fields, and
experience a real functional app. In
cursor, I can now interact with all
elements. The buttons are clickable. The
input fields accept text and subtle
animations enhance the experience.
However, I noticed an issue. The button
animations only triggered on hover. I
wanted a mechanical click animation that
would resonate with our design language.
I explained this requirement to Claude
Code. It immediately began implementing
the requested changes. Claude Code
confirmed the mechanical click animation
was successfully implemented. Returning
to the preview, the buttons now provide
that satisfying click response we
wanted. Now that one page of my design
is ready, I can ask it to reuse the
design for other components and pages as
well. For example, here I've asked it to
create another page for ride booking and
it has gone ahead and created this new
page right here, fully animated and
fully functional. Now I can use this to
design my whole app. With the design
complete, I can convert this into any
framework I choose. Through this
iterative process, you'll eventually
reach a point where the UI meets your
vision perfectly. I discovered another
resource called Animattopi. This site
offers a curated collection of detailed
animation effects that can elevate your
design. You can browse through various
animations and select ones that
complement your project. The
implementation is straightforward.
Simply copy the HTML and CSS code
provided to your coding agent and it
seamlessly integrates into your
application. This tool is perfect for
adding those small meaningful
interactions that truly enhance user
experience. Sometimes it's these subtle
details that make the biggest difference
in how users perceive and interact with
your design. Over on the AI Labs Discord
community, we're hosting our first ever
hackathon, now extended until August
11th. We heard your feedback and wanted
to give you more time to build something
awesome. We're also adding a $500 prize
for the best overall submission. Plus,
the top five projects will be featured
in an upcoming YouTube video. So, take
your time, push your creativity, and
submit your best work. Join by clicking
the link in the pinned comment below.
And if you're enjoying the content, make
sure to hit that subscribe button so you
don't miss what's coming next. Now, what
if you wanted to implement your design
with pre-built components? Let's say
Shad CN UI, which is one of the best
component libraries out there. It has
beautifully designed components and many
sites like Superbase use it for their
front end. The best solution I found is
that you need to provide Claude code
with the proper context of these
components so it knows how they're built
and how to structure them correctly. For
that, I use the Shad CN MCP server. You
can see that I've installed the Shad CN
MCP server right inside Claude Code. And
I've actually been using a workflow with
this MCP server that ensures whenever I
implement any front end using Shad CN,
everything works perfectly and nothing
breaks. So this is the usage rule that I
use with this MCP server. And I've put
this rule in a slash command. You can
see the project structure right here.
It's in the commands folder for the /ash
commands. And I can basically call it
whenever I want. What I use it for is
first of all planning out whatever front
end I want to build. So for example, in
this prompt that you see right here, I
ran the shad CN prompt and told it that
I need to plan the app using shad CN
components and put the whole plan it
generates inside implementation.md. I
then gave it the PRD for the app and
what it was going to do. Claude Code
went ahead and using this MCP server
generated this implementation plan on
how it was going to be built using the
MCP server. After I'm done with the
implementation plan, I call the shad CN/
command again and tell it that it needs
to implement the app and tag the
implementation plan. And then using
this, it actually goes ahead and
implements it using the shad CN
components. The reason why it's so
effective is that the shad CN MCP server
contains all the context for all the
components. And in the plan it basically
states that whenever it needs to plan or
execute meaning apply the shad CN
components it always needs to use that
MCP. So it always has the context on how
to do the implementation and therefore
the chances of errors are reduced by a
lot. I'll link a video in the
description for its complete
installation so you can set it up for
yourself. Now this is the dashboard that
it was able to make using the Shad CNMCP
and you can see for yourself that it's
much better and much more organized. If
I had done it without the MCP, I would
have had to organize a lot of things
manually. There would have been
overlapping elements and I would have
had to fix all of that. But here,
everything is working. Even dark mode
and light mode have been implemented
properly. And that wouldn't have been
possible without the MCP server. But now
that you've actually built and organized
your site, what you can do is start
customizing it. So the site that I use
to customize the Shad CN UI components
is called Tweak CN. And it's a really
amazing site where you can basically
just go ahead and either choose from a
pre-made set of themes or create your
own. For example, let's say I like this
theme and I want to go ahead and
implement it on the app I created. I can
just go ahead and copy this CSS and you
can see that I gave it to Claude code
and this is what it gave me in return.
You can see that the theme was correctly
applied and it really is that easy to
get a design language of your own using
these shad CN components. Now, what if
you don't want to create your own
designs or don't want to implement the
shad CN components? What you can do
instead is take already existing designs
and their structures and basically just
copy them, then start implementing your
own data from there. To do that, your
best bet is using the firecrawl MCP.
What this MCP does is crawl the site and
fetch all of its metadata, the image
links, the animations they use,
everything. Using that, Claude Code can
actually clone the sites. As you can
see, the fire crawl MCP has been added
to Claude Code. I came back and told it
that I wanted a onetoone clone of the
firecrawl site itself and it went ahead
and started implementing it. This is
what it came up with. The structure and
the elements that were used were cloned,
but the colors and the styling were a
little bit off. So, I think adding a
screenshot with the prompt would improve
this. I've also used this before and we
tried to clone the Obsidian website with
this. It worked really well on that. You
can see the result right here. This is
what it cloned and it's a much better
clone compared to the one it did here
with Firecraw. I don't know why it
didn't clone it as well here, but still
this is your best bet for cloning one:1
sites because of the metadata. But let's
say that if you want to clone Figma
designs instead of actual sites, then
you can use the Figma MCP server as
well. The Figma MCP server is really
cool because you can just open up a
Figma design, copy a link to a
selection, and send it back to Claude
Code. It will actually clone that design
and make it exactly like the Figma file
because essentially you're passing the
Figma metadata of the design. I'll link
an installation guide for both of these
MCP servers and you can try them on your
own. That brings us to the end of this
video. If you'd like to support the
channel and help us keep making videos
like this, you can do so by using the
super thanks button below. And as
always, thank you for watching and I'll
see you in the next one.